[Music]
look what I become
so so the goal of today's podcast is to
help me be better at pronouncing names
words different kind of words right if
it's a wedding's day if it's government
if it's lethargy lethargy things that's
the goal of today and I'm willing I'm
open to it just so you guys know we have
a special guest with us who uh came all
the way from UK magic Nawaz uh if you
don't know about Majid Nawaz he's a
founding chairman of killium a British
Think Tank focus on counterterrorism
specifically against islamists he's a
former member of the islamist group
guys that's good we got it in 2012 he
published an autobiography radical and
has since become a prominent critic of
Islam uh islamism in the UK his second
book Islam and the future of Tolerance
in 2015 co-authored with atheist author
Sam Harris was published October of
2015. magic thank you so much for being
a guest it's good to meet you guys yes
it's uh we've been looking forward to
this this is an interesting conversation
to have with you so for some that don't
know your background if you don't mind
taking a moment and sharing your
background that'd be great how long do
you have yeah we got two hours
I could start from the beginning but um
I'll give you the short version and you
can unpick it as you like that
absolutely so I joined hezbo Tahir at
the age of 16 after facing uh some very
severe violent uh racist attacks where I
grew up in Essex in the UK being
um the number of people that looked like
me you could count on perhaps one hand
uh and it was a very different time we
were the first generation
um born and raised in the UK to Muslim
parents and so it was it was a an
interesting experiment because we are
the fourth I'm 45 years old now so we
were the first generation to have this
um these questions around identity in
the west being Muslim uh our parents as
migrants never really had to face those
questions because they were always the
migrants who came so they were still
always in my case my parents came from
Pakistan they were Pakistani migrants in
Britain but we being born and raised
there had to kind of grapple with these
questions of what it meant to be a
Muslim born in the west so when we were
facing a lot of that violent racism
and I'm talking machete attacks Hammer
attacks when I say violent it was brutal
um I witnessed my first murder at 17 uh
stabbing to death who was doing the
attacking
British so this was a group of neo-nazis
uh they affiliated with combat 18 uh
which is a um if it was formed as a
paramilitary organization in Northern
Ireland by serving soldiers who were
fighting the Irish republicanism there
and they became Uber nationalist in that
sense and uh 18 stands for the order of
the letters in the alphabet of Adolf
Hitler's initials so a being one and H
being eight these were guys they weren't
messing around uh multiple friends of
ours had either had hammers put to their
heads and
stabbed all over their bodies and we
I've been as I say but before that
murder at 17 but most of my uh I
witnessed more knife fights in my
teenage years than most people uh and
participated in that most people will
have in their entire lives um that has a
brutalizing effect on the psychology of
a young boy
so at 16
um with the Bosnia genocide unfolding in
Europe against again in its Revenue in
particular against Muslims I became very
very disassociated from society uh
became very angry with the world and at
16 as I say joined hezbo Tahir uh that
took me on another sort of chapter it
was a long journey I ended up on their
leadership I ended up exporting the
group from Britain to Denmark to
Pakistan where I was the one of the
first British Pakistani members to
co-found the organization in Pakistan uh
we uh our aim was to create a global
um theocracy in the name of my faith
tradition which I still adhere to and do
not reject whatsoever just to make that
clear to everybody what I critiqued was
the politicization of that Faith
tradition but the aim at the time we
wanted to create a global theocracy that
would impose one reading of that Faith
tradition over Society
um by law ironically a very European
westphalian concept which was
uh I I I owed more to
um
colonialism and the interwar uh fascism
period than it did to the tradition so
the pluralistic tradition of Islam but
that's what we discuss in that book you
mentioned with Sam Harris but um I ended
up as I say exporting this revolution to
various countries ended up in Egypt I
landed one day before the 9 11 attacks
and the security climate around the
world completely changed
um and we though we were not non-violent
we were if you like
um we were the trotskies to the stalins
of that kind of world so we were more on
the intellectual revolutionary side as
opposed to violence 9 11 changed the
calculation for everybody and in Egypt
they had a security round up after 9 11
and we were rounded up with hundreds of
Egyptians
um uh we were
then blindfolded
um we had our hands tied behind our
backs it with Rags they'd run out of
handcuffs the handcuffs they rounded up
so many people uh we were then taken
into their dungeons where they began
torturing everybody with uh
electrocution eventually uh we were
after a period of solitary confinement I
think about three and a half months
eventually we were put on trial and I
was sentenced to five years as a
political prisoner Tried by an emergency
court in Egypt not under the
Constitutional setup but tried in the
State of Emergency the Hosny Mubarak had
kept in that country since the
assassination of Anwar Sadat in 1981. uh
the country never left the state of
emergency so they were able to
arbitrarily detain people they had
forget guantanama Bay to be honest it
was a picnic compared to what we saw uh
they had people in in prisons without
charge and without trial for over 20
years but in addition to the torture
which wasn't just stress positions as it
is and I say just obviously every form
of torture is um is abhorrent but what
we see in in the Press about
um uh Guantanamo Bay and even abor was
nothing compared to what was going on
inside these prisons uh all uh mind you
while Tony Blair was taking free
holidays um being hosted by Jose Mubarak
while we were in those prisons as the
letters have recently been leaked where
Sherry Blair his wife has been
discussing those free holidays uh I
don't forget things like that but either
way
we were sentenced to five years at which
point we were adopted by Amnesty
International as prisoners of conscience
because as I say there was no suggestion
even in the trial of any violence and I
spent the next five years in uh four and
a bit to be precise in maseraton prison
with the surviving assassins of the
former president Anwar Sadat with the
leaders and founders of all of the
Jihadi as well as islamist groups in
Egypt at the time uh the leaders and
founders of Gamal islamia you're all in
there together in there together as I
say the Assassins of Van wise were there
those who weren't executed in the case
they all became friends of mine the
leader of the Muslim Brotherhood
um uh Dr mohammedia Who Wasn't the
leader at the time he is now Muhammad
Morsi who since died he became the
leader after Mubarak was overthrown uh
amen Nord was a liberal prisoner from
Hezbollah Hezbollah
uh so we had uh pretty much it was a
political University how long were you
guys all together
um for the entire time in that prison so
I was there for just over four years
yeah so is this if if I'm painting a
picture of my mind was this daily
conversations debates you know going
through history you know ideas being
talked about is that kind of how it was
absolutely I I was a student at the time
I was studying Arabic I'm a graduate um
in Arabic in the Arabic language from
soas part of the University of London
and that's ostensibly why I went to
Egypt so I continued with my studies I
spent that time in uh prison studying uh
all all aspects of Islamic theology
um Islamic exegesis
Quran recitation and memorization Arabic
language the fossa the classical Arabic
language
which is the Jewish Prudence Hadith the
uh science of Hadith interpretation uh
it because we had uh people in there
that there was no Rhyme or Reason as to
who was thrown in there other than
suspicion of a you know by a dictator so
you had genuine win scholars in there as
well and we I spent most of my time
studying and debating who was who was
most uh convincing
and simply because they were good at
debating and who was who was most
convicted in their beliefs
I have very little difficulty
differentiating between polemicists and
uh substance because I spent most of my
life training other people in how to
argue and and convince people so for me
it wasn't about poemics and um you spend
most of your life teaching people how to
argue and debate yep because hezbollah's
methodology was ideological propaganda
we we trained people in uh in idle in
some of the tactics you saw uh During
the covid period which we can come to uh
weren't new to me at all we would train
people in in in the methods of
dissemination of ideas for the purposes
of ideological Warfare
um and that's why we were put in jail
because that was deemed very dangerous
our purpose was to recruit army officers
uh and to eventually convince them to
instigate military coups did you succeed
I've recruited a few army officers yeah
yeah in Pakistan and uh and um mainly in
Pakistan actually the the people I spoke
to at the time so if you can if you can
go back and and the again for you to be
in there it's kind of like a story of
somebody saying yeah you know I was in
Rucker you know a park and I was there
and for about two years it was me
Michael you know such and such and Joe
Kobe and all these I mean obviously
these guys come from different areas but
if you put all of them at the same time
and they're all think tank for two years
what are those games like so what are
the conversations like so for me what
I'm asking you is who was most
convincing where you sat there and you
said that's a very good point they're
making for doing this for example if we
make an argument of U.S is the biggest
enemy and here's what they're doing and
you're like okay that's a very good
argument I've never heard before versus
who was a hundred percent convicted that
you couldn't sway them at all based on
your memories so the by the time we got
in there was a movement afoot in Egypt
and across the Islamic world of what was
called The Mirage at which is the
revisions of jihadist ideology and there
were books written by some of the
leaders of these Jihadi groups by the
leaders of Gamal islamia for example I
still have those books at home in Arabic
with my hand written annotations on the
sidelines of those books and the these
were revisions of jihadist thought that
were that I think were profoundly
impactful and they were genuine and uh
really influential in convincing a lot
of these uh more hardcore militant
ideologues that violence isn't the way
to bring about change isn't yeah
terroristic violence is not the way to
bring about political change so they
they were um they were conversations we
were having as I say with former members
Founders and leaders of gamalislamia
um the Assassins of Sadat had also come
to those conclusions and had abandoned
their former jihadist ideology if
islamism is the desire to impose one
version of Islam over Society uh
jihadism is the use of force to bring
about islamism just to be clear and when
I use those term those terms that's what
I mean that's very distinct from Islam
and Jihad Islam is a faith tradition
that is known it's one of the abrahamic
faiths and Allah in Aramaic means God
Jesus when he spoke Aramaic would say
Allah or Elohim
went to Syrian Aramaic we say absolutely
so it just means the same word it's the
same Source uh God I don't use there's a
word because I think it's loaded in the
English language so even in English when
I'm speaking I prefer to say Allah just
so people understand that um ultimately
we're speaking of the same subject
matter here and and Islam in that sense
is is distinct from islamism the desire
to impose Islam over Society Jihad
coming back to those terms again and
means struggle
so in the verb you can say it just means
I struggle and then of course there are
many various manifest manifestations of
struggle primarily we are our enemies is
within us and our solution often and
always actually is within us as well so
struggle uh should be seen in that
context of the struggle struggle to
overcome ourselves
um it can be a struggle against the
other in many instances such as
occupation I'm the pacifist if somebody
invades Britain I will fight
and so I think that um jihadism though
is that is is the is the use of force to
impose islamism so that's why I Define
these terms so we're not talking of
Islam and Jihad back to your question I
haven't forgotten
um in in the prisons there were people
that were still subscribing to the
islamist and jihadist ideologies and
wanted to either use Force to impose
that on others or take over a system and
do so
but most of the
the leaders and founders of those
organizations by then had come around to
this idea uh that violence wasn't the
way so ironically we were the ideologues
when we were when we entered that jail
now ordinarily when you go through
torture it makes you even more Angry
even more
entrenched in your view and even less
willing to compromise because of the
anger and because of the inability to
separate the pain and the anguish and
the trauma from what you experienced
from being able to think clearly I don't
know for whatever reason in my case I
spent those five years debating And
discussing by the end of it I could I
and I read all those books I mentioned
the Mirage at all the revisions of the
in The jihadist Thinking by the end of
it even though I didn't leave the group
until a year after my departure from
maserat or a prison I could no longer
sustain my own conviction uh that what I
had thought was Islam the faith and
therefore needed to be proselytized uh
was what I had come to believe I could
no longer sustain that conviction and so
I had to uh leave so I'd say I became
influenced by these people that you were
asking of those that in their older
years had matured took one any one above
the other no no it was no collected yeah
it was a collective group of um and it
was so divers and different I mean I
mentioned Eamonn North from Hezbollah he
was a liberal political prisoner we had
um we had uh Sarah Dina Ibrahim was
quite a well-known Egyptian sociologist
who was jailed for questioning mubarak's
attempt uh to to give power to his son
afterwards Jamal Mubarak
um and yet we had Communists in there
obviously the majority were is the
missing jihadists but just to give you
an idea there were there were people
that are converted to Christianity that
were thrown in jail for being apostates
from Islam to Christianity and there
were there were people that converted to
Islam that were thrown in jail and we
had a running joke at the time in prison
that in under Hosni mubarak's Egypt if
you change your mind from anything to
anything it doesn't matter which way you
go thinking is what what would get you
put into prison so imagine the diversity
of thought it was really for me that was
my real University to be honest I bet I
can only imagine I have a question for
you on this diversity of thought and
this sort of conglomerate hodgepodge of
completely different ideologies I kind
of want to get to the heart of the
biggest differences and the biggest
similarities between all these quote
unquote terrorist groups right so Isis
Al-Qaeda the Taliban Hezbollah Hamas the
list goes on on Boko Haram what's not
they're not all the same they all have
different ideologies what is the most
common thread
with all these groups and then
distinguishments between all of them the
Common Thread is that they are all being
weaponized and manipulated by by various
intelligence agencies across the world
that's the Common Thread they're being
weaponized by intelligence agents and
manipulated yeah how uh so these are
proxy wars what you're seeing in Sudan
going on right now is an example of a
proxy war but let's take Isis as an
example
um by now it's well established I'll
give one case study which is actually a
human and sorrowful story shamima begum
is a former British citizenship uh so
who had a passport script she was an
underage child
when she was groomed online by ISIS to
convince her to travel to Syria for the
purposes of Marrying an Isis fighter and
I say marrying uh because it wasn't
really it's child sexual exploitation
she was underage she was in school and
she somehow managed to get over there uh
long story short she's now in one of
those camps like uh Campbell how she's
in one of those camps where they're
holding the wives and children of Isis
Fighters these are prisons in which
children are born
um it's recently been revealed that her
smuggling from Britain from remember a
school girl yeah from Britain to join
Isis and and and become sexually
exploited by these uh terrorists was
facilitated by somebody working for
Canadian intelligence that's no longer
even in doubt
um and so what you end up realizing is
the British government stripped her of
her passport
uh to punish her for the the crime of
traveling over to to join uh or marry uh
in quote quotation marks an Isis fighter
uh but actually it was her her being
smuggled out there was facilitated by
Canadian intelligence it turns out that
we in the west were arming some of those
Fighters like which was al-Qaeda in
Syria because we wanted to overthrow
um Assad in in Syria so the the my work
up until the covid period was to
challenge a lot of the ideological
underpinning
that justified some of this thinking and
that I also in the intellectual not
violent sense succumb to however when
you also then want a fuller picture of
it you have to realize where do the
weapons come from where does the
training come from you see with
Afghanistan and how the Taliban now have
more Blackhawk helicopters than the
entire British Army because of Biden's
uh absolutely cowardly uh and and
shameful way in which he withdrew I've
never been for the occupation but the
way in which he can't run in that way
was shameful and left them with all
those weapons so our own actions also
have to be put into the picture to
understand now as I say what one of the
things they all have in common is that
they are being weaponized for to fight
proxy wars and invariably you see the
case of Syria demonstrates that very
clearly uh because of our desire to
remove Assad who uh I come from a
background where all Arab dictators have
been our enemy I have no sympathy for
Assad but I what I wouldn't want to ever
accept accept is that we replace Assad
with Al-Qaeda and Isis which is what we
were effectively doing is what Trump
brought to an end by the way
um and I think to give you one final
example take Ukraine
and the as of Nazis who aren't even
neo-nazis the actual Nazis they come
from the Bandera tradition which is the
surviving elements of Nazism and the
collaborators in uh in that uh in
Ukraine from the era of uh Nazism up
until today they are still there now as
of now every country has racists but as
of is a battalion that was integrated
into the Ukrainian Army and and formally
became their National Guard so the
Ukrainian National Guard is the as of
Battalion as of our Nazis this is not in
dispute this is not a opinion this is a
matter of fact I for 10 years ran the
world's first and leading
counter-extremism organization it was
our job to brief Prime Ministers and
presidents on who is an extremist I have
met in that Pursuit uh George Bush Tony
Blair David Cameron more heads of state
than I can imagine one-on-one talking
like this I am telling you as of our
Nazis this is not in uh dispute it's a
fact they have not seen Insignia and yet
we're sending weapons and funds to Nazis
who are integrated into the Ukrainian
Army that's like saying that because we
wanted to get rid of Assad we're going
to fund Isis you can't uh Run the World
in a way
where the ends justify the means because
then you have what people call
collateral damage imagine that in the
intellectual side of things you you are
we are funding and weap and arming
people who who have these extremist
ideologies and then we're surprised at
these ideologies spread now my job then
becomes harder because it's not just
against jihadism that I stand but of
course Nazism obviously which is how I
ended up in the first place becoming
radicalized so you've got people like us
saying look you know the world should be
about peace unity love and and meanwhile
the um governments that we are
attempting to counsel in that regard are
doing the exact opposite by arming and
funding these militia uh all over the
world can I just give you this isn't a
pushback this is more of a follow-up but
it'd be almost like if you were starting
a company right and you go to someone
like a PBR starting company right now
and we go to some intelligence agency
for seed capital or to raise some money
okay so maybe they invest in our
business but at the end of the day we
started the business so it almost seems
like you're saying that the intelligence
agencies are facilitating or propping up
a lot of these uh terrorist groups and
that's like if you're peeling an onion
that might be the second third fourth
fifth layer but the bottom layer of the
onion of isil a Al-Qaeda the Taliban is
the group itself it's not the
intelligence agencies oh it's my own no
it's a yes and no it's a it's a mixture
of both because some of the leaders are
actually infiltrators from the security
services I mean there's only so far I
can go into this without being too
scandalous and uh let's get scandalous
here uh but also lives are at stake so I
I think that it's important to recognize
that especially Isis Isis itself is a
creation of these proxy wars especially
Isis where you're correct is the history
yes you're absolutely correct so how uh
um let's start with say um Islamic Jihad
in Egypt how that began
uh is the Muslim Brotherhood were
attempting to create their own version
of this kind of Theocratic thinking and
bring that about in Egypt
um which by the way that one year that
Morsi was in power the leader of the
Muslim Brotherhood after mubarak's
overthrow I mean ultimately as there's a
BBC hard talk interview of me with
Stephen sacker where I'm criticizing the
Muslim Brotherhood government and he
says to me but weren't they elected I
said yeah just like Bush was and I can
still criticize George Bush so I I do
make the point that ultimately they were
elected they were better than a military
dictatorship which is again what we have
now with CeCe so my critique of them
isn't to strip them of the fact that
they were legitimately elected but let's
take the Brotherhood as an example
before this all happened because they've
been around since the 1920s
um they they would be going about their
proselytizing in Egypt and of course
under the dictatorship they weren't
allowed and they would be thrown into
the jails now how they began treating
them is there's a big fortress in Cairo
it's called
it's the Saladin Fortress it's now a
tourist site like the Tower of London
you go there you go into the dungeons
the London dungeon anyone been to the
London dungeon yeah you see all the wax
works of the torture they used to do
today yeah so there's a fortress like
that in in Cairo except it's not
historic it's in our lifetime it was a
torture dungeon and prisoners that I was
with in maserat or a prison were held in
that Fortress which is an ancient
Fortress but the regime had converted it
to a torture dungeon now in that the
Fortress uh they would get the Muslim
Brotherhood prisoners and they would
basically starve dogs for um a long time
and then the starving dogs would be let
loose in the solitary cell with these
prisoners to basically terrorize them
and torture them now this kind of
treatment raping wives in front of
husbands torturing children in front of
fathers to force confessions is how
jihadism emerged in the very prison I
was held in so mazaratura prison is
the infamous founding ideologue of
modern day jihadism who wrote the book
The Das capital of jihadism called
milestones
in Arabic now Milestones was written in
the prison I was held in and it was
written by a former Muslim Brotherhood
member now what you said by the way Adam
and I didn't mean to say you're all
wrong because that's where what you said
applies this is an example where we have
to take Muslims have to take
responsibility for what happened next so
he's very angry he's they've witnessed
all this torture he then does what I I
did the opposite of this right he then
codifies a dogmatic rigid way of
thinking to make themselves feel better
about the fact they're angry and that's
where Milestones came from and that was
the basis the intellectual basis for
modern day Al-Qaeda that emerged so
that's how what you said correctly is
how jihadism emerged is I don't think
said gutter was an intelligence
operative he was an angry man who had
been witnessed all of him and his
brothers would witness torture and they
are angry and then they codify their
anger in and justify it by Islam like
everyone does in any every Faith to
tradition I mean Inquisition and the
Crusades are example of that so he
codifies and justifies his anger and
then writes it in a book and that then
then takes off so yes that's how it
began but by the time you get to the end
of it with Isis more so than not Isis is
a creation of these proxy wars and
intelligence is why uh I have to be as
candid as I am about this because we've
gotta everyone has to take
responsibility for what's going on the
name of the book real quick so we can
pull that up oh Milestones
it's it's um there it's available in
English it's it's the pretty much the
intellectual foundation for modern day
jihadism you compared it to Dallas
Capital yeah it's an inter it's an it's
it's one of the first examples of the uh
of a jihadist Manifesto Manifesto It's
the articulation of jihadist's thinking
imagine I have two questions so when uh
the torture of the prisons that like you
were in is it do they have like a
regimen thing of how like they schedule
it was like an everyday thing was it
ranking on who they thought was a bigger
threat out that they wanted information
was it a was it a constant thing and my
second question was with the bush and
Blair you said you spoke to both of them
how does how did that
feel and how that play out sitting there
talking with two people that started the
Iraq War started that which was just a
Snowball Effect got rid of Saddam who
started a lot of all these yeah all
these problems yeah look I think there's
a political I I'll say the word
Reckoning but I mean political Reckoning
yeah but not violence there's a
political Reckoning coming for
um for a cabal or a clique of world
leaders who are responsible on their
side of it for much of this so bush is
an example Tony Blair's an example uh
they invaded Iraq on false pretenses we
now know all of that was based on a lie
again back to Adam to your point that's
why I say we all have to take
responsibility for the full picture here
yeah and just like I believe Muslims
have to take responsibility to clean
house as well right which is what we've
been doing for the last uh since I I
left that group in 2008 uh with much
sacrifice but it's not easy to do what I
do uh and and me and my brothers what we
do is not easy because as you can
imagine it's faced with a lot of
pushback as well but everyone has to
take responsibility so there's a
political Reckoning coming because these
guys
um ruined the entire Middle East uh it
is I cannot overstate the damage that
the invasion of Iraq and then you know
with Afghanistan added to that and then
Syria and what happened there I cannot
overstate the damage that's done to the
world and how difficult it's made uh
everyone's jobs
um and they they haven't stopped I mean
during the covid Mandate period um again
for the record I opposed every single
coveted mandate and lost my job over it
I was a national radio broadcaster in
the UK on the largest commercial radio
station but uh I basically opposed every
single mandate masks I flew in fact I
flew with um
uh to Tennessee without a mask on and
posted a photo and then the chief of
staff of the government wanted to meet
me when I landed because they tell me
about flying without a mask it was
surreal but um we've got it so just as
when that mandate period emerged and
Tony Blair started again pushing for
digital IDs and for synchronizing
everybody up with the technocracy these
people want Total Control it's why we
call them globalists they want total
technocratic control of everything we do
filter through their systems their
infrastructure with no privacy so they
can see and and hear everything
um and that's the same cabal that
invaded Iraq it's the same cabal that
has been through them the money
laundering in Ukraine and and pushing
for more and more war and the
securitization of our societies as a
result of that so there is a I think
there is a political Reckoning that is
long overdue and and I think Trump is
one manifestation of that political uh
Reckoning and in the UK Nigel farage is
an example of what happens when you
allow the established to get away with
impunity for decades committing crimes
invading countries there's still a CBS
60 Minutes clip of Madeleine Albright
the late Madeleine Albright she's passed
away so I've met her as well I won't say
anything rude about dead people that's
uh Prophet teaches us
um he says do not abuse the dead for you
only harm the living so when we speak of
the dead people even if we oppose them
vehemently we speak in terms of ideas
and themes as opposed to making it
personal so she was asked by Leslie
Stahl on CBS 60 Minutes that half a
million children died in Iraq this is
the war before The Invasion and uh this
clip still up online widely available
and Leslie style uh who I've also met
because they did a 60-minute segment on
me as well but Leslie style says to
Madeleine Albright you know that's half
a million children is the price worth it
and Madeleine Albright says yeah we
believe the price is worth it uh and
this is these these children died many
believe from the effects of depleted
uranium that was used in Iraq but the
you know you've got a situation where
the entire world has been ruined by this
cabal who continue to act with impunity
even here in the United States of
America I think I think Vinnie brought
up a very good point about the Bush
Administration yeah I guess my question
to the follow-up is what level of
involvement should the United States
play in the Middle East obviously we got
out of Afghanistan Iraq was a disaster
we saw what happened with Isis and isil
but when when we leave the Middle East
that opens up a vacuum for Russia to
come in and Putin to do what he's want
to do China is investing in Iran and
different uh parts of the Middle East
you know obviously I don't I think we've
learned the hard way we can't just place
our values of democracy and freedom into
the Middle East and like hey go for it
guys yeah but should America just
completely
vacate Middle East like what level of
involvement should America I mean so
let's start with that's a really good I
think it's a good exploration here let's
start with the aim I think the aim
should be
um
a more multilateral world that works
together
and so that doesn't mean Chinese
domination it doesn't mean Russian
domination so uh just over a year ago I
was on the JRE the Rogan uh podcast and
uh
um I believe he speaks highly of you
Patrick I saw a clip where he's very
happy with you
um it I was warning at the time before
this whole Ukraine uh Saga sort of and
the FTX thing blew it up and the way it
did and I was saying this is all a
mistake because what we're doing is
going to push Russia and China together
well that's what's happened since
they've basically formed an alliance and
it's very interesting because if you see
what China's managed to do
nobody thought it would be possible to
pull from under the feet of everybody to
pull the rug in the way that they have
done between Saudi Arabia and Iran China
negotiated a peace deal between Saudi
Arabia and Iran which one hopes will
bring an end to the slaughter in Yemen
where it's been horrific with children
Starving in the way that you see the
images coming from Yemen it's terrible
so the hopes that what we're seeing now
let's take the Abraham Accords and the
UAE and Israel negotiating with each
other and now let's take Saudi and Iran
negotiating with each other the the Aram
Accords had American sponsorship the
Saudi Iran deal had Chinese sponsorship
if we can all recognize that this the
way forward isn't occupation Invasion
and funding Wars but funding and
sponsoring peace and these forms of
negotiations I'm I'm not opposed to
either of them the abrahamic what you
may well be aware of them Adam but the
Abraham Accords that's right and and it
was just you know the idea that
um Israel can have uh cooperation with
the middle least and trade or the idea
that Saudi and Iran can do so neither
should be rejected we've got to stop
these wars because nothing good comes
from them and they're all proxy wars the
one in Yemen between the houthis and the
yemeni authorities was a proxy war the
houthis being effectively backed by Iran
and Saudi backing the yemeni authorities
and it led to masslot and mass killing
um as well going on to this day that's
right but one hopes that this a
negotiated peace that's being between
Saudi and Iran China has been sponsoring
so now why I mention that is China has
made an offer to zelenski so what I've
been a very vocal critic of China I
before my cancellation I launched a well
it eventually turned out to be a four I
think it was four day hunger strike
um while I was on air and uh the aim was
to gather a hundred thousand signatures
on a parliamentary website which would
trigger a debate in Parliament to
recognize the plight of the oygar Muslim
people in China who are an ethnic
minority group that are
being targeted and discriminated against
by the Chinese Communist party because
of course the presence of any
traditional religious identity under
communism is a problem how do you
pronounce it
um I I that pronunciation I won't vouch
for because I don't speak the oil
language we've heard uyghurs a million
times but so so the um is the head of
the UK world or you go to Congress okay
and she attempts to correct me when I
say uyghurs okay
um and the correction I can't vouch for
but how you heard me pronounce it there
isn't yeah don't take my word you just
say way more ethnic than I do I say like
a white guy weaker
yeah so I I that is an example of me not
being a great fan of the Chinese regime
and but I try and give credit where
credit is due and we've got to recognize
that if we want the kind of world uh
that I hope we all want which is uh more
peaceful more united in in a spiritual
sense more multilateral then we've got
to recognize China exists and where
they're doing good like negotiating
peace between uh Iran and Saudi Arabia
we've got to say that's good you know I
got a question for you so one of the
things that's happened in in the US is
common sense is being seen like a bad
idea and bad ideas are creating a lot of
momentum because people are not pushing
back you said something earlier where
one of the things you were trained to do
was to debate and to teach others how to
convert and debate right so and and you
so you said you saw some of that during
covet that's why you didn't fall forward
you kind of you know unpacking that and
we're seeing some of this woke ideology
in the U.S that's creating a lot of
momentum which makes no sense how a
woman who's been a feminist her entire
life to defend women now a man who
identifies as a woman
is able to come and take the freedoms
away from other women who that feminist
once fought for which makes no sense
right so how did you if you were trained
how to convert people into possibly bad
ideas which is what you did at one point
how did you do that how were you so
successful at it
how did I uh how did I uh convert people
to these ideas yes what did you lean on
did you lean on innocence did you lean
on anger did you lean on rage did you
divide yeah what angles did you take
that's you've got to understand human
psychology really and what you just said
there at the end of that question is an
example of correct what the approaches
you've got to unders if somebody's angry
then how do you manipulate and weaponize
that anger by steering it now I don't
want to get overly complicated so I'll
give a a more popular example which
everyone will get immediately so we all
imagine watch Star Wars right of course
right so uh the way in which through the
prequels you see Darth Vader become who
Darth Vader becomes and and what happens
to Anakin is an example of what I'm
talking about how you can weaponize and
manipulate anger that comes from Rage
from Love in Anakin's case losing a
loved one right so if you can sympathize
with a human story as it's presented in
Star Wars you can see in real life how
that happens so in a fictional or
character who loses a loved one too I
think remind me was a natural death that
Anakin um
Anakin's lover died of whatever it was
imagine you're in a war zone where your
entire family's been blown up it becomes
incredibly easy to weaponize and
manipulate that anger Isis began in the
in the prisons in Iraq for example so
you've got a whole bunch of people whose
country's been invaded and they're
fighting an occupier and they get caught
and they're put into jail and of course
they're angry and that's where that
anger was weaponized again when I say by
the security services in isis's case up
until Isis they were Al-Qaeda Fighters
so I I think it's whether it's anger or
every every emotion every human emotion
can be steered
for the purposes of achieving an outcome
and it was done during covet fear in the
case of covid with covid mandates and
again everything I say please everybody
listening look it up for yourselves
don't believe me when I say things like
uh we we witnessed the uh historically
the largest and most Sinister
psychological operations campaign uh
inflicted upon civilian uh people by
their governments uh during the covert
era this isn't again is no longer in
dispute uh the fact that the that
whether the Twitter files have revealed
it here in the uh in the US or to by way
of an example Matt Hancock the health
secretary's WhatsApp messages that were
leaked revealed in the UK where he's
like how do we make the people more
scared ultimately we which we've spoken
not all of that on the path that's right
and and the 77th Brigade that I first
mentioned on the uh JRE but mentioned
here again is the is a UK based uh
military operations unit called the the
77th Brigade which on their own website
they state that their purpose is
psychological operations and they were
engaged in this whole covert situation
Twitter was infiltrated by uh operatives
in that way to manipulate our perception
of uh of reality so in the case of covid
they did it with fear in the case of
extremism you do it for example with
anger you could do it with love I mean I
think the Spanish Inquisition was a
manipulation of Love interestingly
enough because the idea you know I will
torture you because it's good for you
and God will redeem you through this and
then when he's seeking Heretics the idea
is you think that you're seeking Purity
and love and of course the road to hell
is paved with good intentions yeah and
but I'm sorry I want to go deeper in
this I want to go deeper you talk about
the Leslie Stahl video I just texted you
Rob if you want to play this is 23
seconds from 60 minutes and you see
decisions like this being made this is
in 2001 I may be off but if you can play
it
we have heard that
having children
that's more about children than died
when in Hiroshima
you know is the price worth it I think
this is a very hard choice but the price
we think the price is worth it
okay 1996 when this happened okay yeah
that's another clip you got playing Rob
maybe okay so uh that was the first Iraq
yeah that wasn't 96 that was a second
clip that just to be clear that 1968
yeah I think so so you know you think
about decisions like that being made
okay we think it was worth it yeah all
right you know uh uh fear covet Was Fear
I agree love you're doing this for God
and some people would say even you know
religious extremists hey you're you know
killing your life you know taking your
life and God's gonna be very happy for
you or Kamikaze right or you know all
these other things that we've all heard
about but I want you to go a little bit
deeper if you can because
you know I I had a girl I hired lady she
wasn't a girl a lady I hired to be one
of my copywriters years ago hmm
and then one day we sit down and two
years later after she's been working
with me and she says you know I got to
tell you why I took this job I said tell
me why I took the job well let me tell
you my background my background is I was
one of those people that bought into a
cult-like leader and I said who and she
mentioned it to me who to call lead was
I said you were part of that because I
was part of that cult so what things
happened well we all I as a woman I was
married but we had sex with this and
this and that and she's telling me as a
married woman her husband was okay that
other men of that members what convinced
you of that because I was convinced we
were doing the right thing and me and my
husband all this stuff typically it
comes from a place of wanted to be part
of a community right this is happening
and parents in America are very worried
some of them that can't afford to send
their kids to private school they have
to send their kids to public school and
in public school this is happening but
if you can I want you to go a little
deeper I know you were doing a Star Wars
thing and I know you kind of you know
use that as the analogy but I want you
to actually you know tell us what it
would sound like for example hey how do
you feel about the fact that such and
such is getting all the credit and
you're not right don't you hate it that
you know they don't they don't really
realize you're doing all the work behind
closers without you he would never be
where he's at right now that's one
method right hey did you see what they
did to your family we have to seek
Vengeance we have to go back and do this
right can you actually unpack some of
those recruiting methods yeah
so
um you can break an idea down generally
into the political so with the purposes
of extremist recruiting you could break
an idea down into its political
um manifestation it's scriptural uh uh
perspective as well and a rational uh
perspective so let me let me break that
down on the idea of democracy we were uh
we were trained to completely remove the
idea of democracy as having any appeal
to our target audience because clearly
we wanted a theocracy instead now take
the political it's very easy to do with
democracy actually because it's been
such a sham
um even here in America with Biden and
the old fudge with the election
um all of this is coming out the whole
j6 stuff it's all it's all been a
theater but um you know I think it's by
now it's how are people falling for
because people are in their Echo
Chambers but let me just because your
question you've asked it twice let me go
into a bit of detail on that and then
clearly we've come to the j6 and all
that if you want as well but um
uh let's take democracy as an idea
um political the political attack from
our proselytizing perspective our
ideological Warfare angle it's easy to
politically attack democracy what I mean
by the political attack is you take this
idea you say right these people claim to
believe in democracy and yet they don't
even adhere to it themselves so for
example is it how uh can you claim that
democracy is what you want for uh the
Arab world when you've just invaded and
occupied a country that's a political
critique of the idea and that would be
easy to do because our actions have
demonstrated that you know the hypocrisy
that
the scriptural references then you know
you again depending on the person you're
speaking if it's a politically active
person you might want to come in with a
political critique first if you're
talking to a religious person who's
traditionally religious and you're I and
your aim is to politicize them because
traditionally devout Muslims weren't
politicized
um and and the faith had always been an
internal uh uh thing uh but we used to
politicize traditionally develop Muslims
so how would you do that you would take
scripture because that's what they hold
dear as opposed to the political line
and the scriptural references so you
would seek to convince them
that there is a shortcoming or a
misunderstanding in their idea of Islam
and Islam is founded on this key
fundamental point of dohid or the belief
in the Oneness
of the source of the uh of Allah
and so what's saying did in Milestones
the book that you just showed on screen
is to take this idea of heed or Oneness
and demonstrate that you as a Muslim are
falling short of your fundamental
religious obligation to uh to this idea
of one Allah if you allow rival Gods to
be created in the form of these rulers
and then you bring scriptural references
to back that which is actually quite a
revolutionary point which wasn't made in
Islamic discourse before I'd say moldy
he was the founder of jamati Islam in
the Indian subcontinent and molduli was
followed then
by people like said caught up in
milestones and and nabahani who was the
founder of Hezbollah the group that I
joined but molduri was one of the first
to make this point the idea that
passages such as in
the Quran which means uh the Hokum is
for none but Allah now the word hukum
here could mean uh judgment in the
arbitration sense or it could mean rule
in the theocracy sense yeah as in law
now what the modern day recruiters would
do is take that I did as well you take
that passage and say look see this
rule is for none but Allah so these
rulers who are ruling with their
man-made uh dictatorial uh laws are
challenges are a direct challenge to
Allah's rule yeah and we have a complete
system of governance that has been
discarded by these dictators who have
become Idols before Allah and shirk or
Idol or polytheism is seen as the the
biggest anathema to dulheed or the
Oneness of Allah right so you can take
somebody down that Journey now the truth
is this passage could not mean what we
were teaching people it meant it's
impossible because the idea of a
unitary legal system imposing one law
over all of society is a modern
westphalian European nation-state idea
the idea of State a state yeah
is a modern idea it doesn't exist in
traditional scripture the word State
Arabic is dollar you will if you were to
take a computer to scan the entire
all Islamic scripture to look for the
word dollar or state you could do it
right now if you want it just doesn't
exist it is not there
the closest you'll get is a word Doula
in the sense of the rotation of money
um and and and debt but there's no such
word as Dola or for example Navan which
means a system uh or Constitution which
means distur in Arabic right these words
are conspicuous by their absence in
traditional Islamic discourse and that's
not a that's not surprising because they
are very modern political Concepts in
the first place uh and so when we used
to take these words these passages like
to say this means that the rule must be
for none but Allah and the Constitution
therefore must be based on Islam we were
basically imposing very modern uh into
Wars I say interwar European ideas
onto traditional Islamic scripture to
extract from that apolitical ideology so
that's the scriptural angle that you
could take as opposed to the political
angle then there's the I said the
rational angles to break down the
problem inherent in the idea of
democracy
um and that is an angle to say look you
know when demos craters the idea of the
Greeks the slaves couldn't vote
um who gets to decide uh what you vote
for what you uh what you're even
thinking because if you don't have money
you can't campaign and therefore
democracy really is who gets to be the
biggest billionaire and that this would
be a rational critique of the idea as
opposed to pointing to its hypocrisy uh
the political critique or the scriptural
uh references that I just went through
so you can take any idea and break it
down in those three for the purposes of
recruitment
so how much of it is in the guide that
can give the best argument how much of
it is in the guide that has the money
in the sense of what I'm saying yeah
it's actually more than that it's what
the circumstances are conducive to so if
you if you're taking Rock for example it
was a no-brainer take Afghanistan it's a
no-brainer that the um the jihadists are
going to win the argument there I'm not
going to win an argument if you've got
occupation forces yeah in the it's just
it's I can be a everything I'm saying
today may sound really nice and smart it
doesn't matter During the covid period I
was saying this at the the antimony
covert stuff I was saying it on air to I
mean it was a huge audience
um on the largest commercial radio
platform in the UK and my show was on a
weekend lunch time with over half a
million listeners when people should be
out having their weekend brunches
and it it didn't land why because when
people are scared they're not looking I
mean instead I got sacked right
um I mean it landed in the sense like
obviously the argument in the end won I
think we won that argument in the end
and even if people haven't realized it
yet I think they will eventually but at
the time it didn't change government it
didn't change politicians thinking it
didn't change the people that needed to
be influenced by that argument weren't
listening because they were scared
if you're in under occupation you're not
going to listen to the majids or the my
brothers that work with me on this kind
of stuff because that if you're under
occupation you're angry so those
emotions whether it's fear whether it's
anger even love which can blind if if
the con if the conditions aren't
conducive to what I'm saying which is
why I'm saying that the China negotiated
peace between Iran and Saudi or the
Abraham Accords this will all calm the
situation down in the Middle East and we
need a Karma situation to be able to
have these kinds of conversations
so you know that's interesting you gave
a little bit of context I I wanted to
get a little bit more strategic about it
on how it happens because it's happening
right now all over the place
and people don't know how to fight
against it you want to trans stuff you
want to talk about that yeah you know
it's not just yeah I want to talk about
the trans stuff I want to talk about all
this stuff but I want to know how to
weaponize people to argue against it
because they're cornered so sometimes
they're like man I can't say anything
here I feel like I got nothing to say
here so but but while we're on this
topic before we get to that I want to
kind of unpack this one here
you know you take scripture and The
Interpreter whoever the pastor is can
take one and you know spin it and say
this is why God said 10 but what it
really meant is that if you give 30 then
you're gonna say I got to give 30
because the guy that you know so I'm
going to this church man instead of I'm
making 20 grand a month I got to give
the church 10 grand a month because
God's gonna give me so there are people
that are very convincing people fall
forward right okay
you set the billions of dollars the
money uh uh it takes a lot of money and
whoever's got the money and is getting
the you know the money to whatever party
it is they're going to be able to get
the argument to go maybe a George Soros
you're seeing what they're doing with
the money right now you saw the moment
Biden announced three major names came
out that they're going to be supporting
him financially Sorrows the sun was one
of them what were the other two names
that were on that list rob it was just
so katzenberg katzenberg Reed Hoffman
and Sorrows hey we're getting behind
Biden and we're going to defend him and
we're going to help him out so this
makes sense from the money standpoint
but I'm going to give you the opposite
side on the religion to see if that's
also applies to religion
uh there's been if you look at the
fastest growing religion right now on
what's going to be the largest religion
in the world 2035 Muslims are ahead yeah
and it's not even close the way they're
grown you can pull up the stat that says
how many per hundred Muslims per 100
people that are born how many are
Christians I think you have the link you
have it right here you you send it to me
so if you want to pull that up it says
per 100 people that are born
um you got 33 are Christians 100 birth
33 are Christians 31 are Muslims okay
but per hundred that die
37 on Christians only 21 are Muslims
yeah okay it's a much younger
demographic it's a much younger
demographic so by 2035 it's going to be
a very different thing so why do you
think the religion the Muslim what
argument does it have that's spreading
the way it is today where it's grown at
the pace is it because it's demographic
based or are they also coming into
Christian regions and converting them as
well so nothing I say here should be
taken as definitive because it's such a
diverse Faith tradition sure but there
are General observations we can make
and one of them I'd start with is to is
to understand there's no church in Islam
which is what our critique of the Saudi
regime has been about
um it's the uh whether you want to call
it the wahhabi doctrine that is the
official established religion in Saudi
Arabia or the salafi doctrine people use
salafi well how be seen as a bit of a
pejorative but actually it it's because
the name of the founder of that Doctrine
um that was his name wahab
um the Saudi merger of religion and
state in that sense
the reason we've just been through
Ramadan and Eid in Mubarak everyone and
the reason there were some Muslims
celebrating on a Friday and some on a
Saturday is because Saudi declared Eid
by citing the moon for shawwal on
Thursday night but other countries
around the world Nigeria Pakistan
included Indonesia Malaysia others they
said we don't have to follow Saudi
Arabia now the reason I give that
example and they said we've cite our own
moon in our country the reason I give
that example is because
um there is no established church like
the Vatican in Islam and so in its
origin from the days of uh prophet
Muhammad's passing onwards there has
never been a establishment version of
Islam and in fact that's what the
islamists are attempting to create
they're attempting to reverse engineer
a a church in Islam but they don't
realize they have more in common with
Catholicism than they do with
traditional Islam in that sense the idea
of theocracy is entirely alien to
Islamic religion I'll give you the
example of turkey so before the ottoman
caliphate was dismantled in 1924 after
World War One the system in place the
legal system in place they had there
again historically verifiable it was
called the Millet system the Millet
system it was a legally pluralistic
system so you had more than one law
operating in turkey at any time if you
had a dispute Patrick
you could go to a if you were a
Christian you could go to a Christian
arbitrator which is why I said the word
hukum actually means arbitration that
earlier passage I was citing doesn't
mean rule it means judgment in other
words arbitration yeah you can
voluntarily go for your own arbitration
so you could choose a Christian I could
choose a Muslim and that Millet system
meant that you had legal pluralism legal
pluralism in the world no longer exists
most countries are now uh unitary legal
systems they only have one law operating
in the country because business won the
argument business wanted legal certainty
you know it's it's more profitable to be
able to predict the law so business
wanted legal certainty so nation states
emerged and you ended up with unitary
legal systems but in the Islamic
tradition the legally pluralistic system
or the Millet system existed because
theocracy was alien to Islam it's why I
say the islamists attempt to bring
theocracy into Islam has more in common
with the Catholic church so what why in
answer to your question when there isn't
a established church
the faith is inherently a faith of the
people and anti-establishment in the
good sense of that word of libertarian
in the libertarian sense of that word so
it's very appealing as a result because
you've got a direct relationship with
the source
and you don't have to confess to anyone
else other than to the source you don't
have to you don't owe anyone anything
else and you can choose who you follow
based upon who you think is sincere as
opposed to the church imposing a Imam
over you you can choose to go to your
local Moscow you can choose to go to
another mosque if you don't like the
Imam there there is no uh membership to
an institution now why that's important
is because I believe
um that's very attractive people sense
that all institutions become corrupted I
I believe on an intellectual level all
institutions drift towards
authoritarianism and that's something
that is inherent to systems that you
cannot avoid they accumulate more and
more power bureaucracies like efficiency
and because bureaucracies like
efficiency they uh over time they
self-correct for more and more
efficiency which means more and more
bureaucracy which means a larger and
larger system and if you if you look at
the nature of systems and how they
behave they generally always drift
towards accumulating more and more
centralized power now that can apply to
a regime or to a system in terms of
government and it can apply also to a
clergy or a religious institution and
what happens then over time is that
whether you see with some of the recent
scandals in the Catholic church or you
see the power grab through the mandates
and the covid Mandate period you end up
with basically people becoming victims
of that institution as it seeks to over
time accumulate more and more power and
so because
again I say these are General marks
because Islam is such a diverse Faith
tradition but in general because there
is no one Islamic church or clergy
uh but despite the islamist attempts to
create one despite Saudi Arabia despite
Iran uh these are contested they're not
traditional uh Islamic clergy in that
sense
um and they're not worldwide
so you have that sense of freedom and
and Liberation that that are direct
connection to the source brings and I
think that's a very appealing element of
it it means that we can have a
relational approach to the tradition
what I mean by relational is it's People
to People
now I know this might sound a bit
abstract I'm going to focus on this for
a second because it's so important it's
actually more important that people give
credit to
and I'll give an example to indicate how
I think it's so important
technocracy if you look at technocracy
and if you look at the world the way in
which um the globalist powers are
seeking to suck all of our data they
recognize that our data is profitable
they recognize that actually we are
valuable because of our data which is
why they want it all the time they want
what you're browsing Patrick right now
on there they want what's on your phone
they want your the patterns of your
behavior because they can be monetized
yeah
so for example every time I use my debit
card to contact pay say I purchased this
bottle here and I make a contactless
payment and if I um and if I'm a
creature of habit and I purchase one of
these at a certain time of the week
before I go to the gym let's say before
I go to the gym I drink one of these
bottles of water after I come out I
drink a protein shake if you can get
that pattern you can time marketing to
my behavior and of course that's a
that's where I've been in the last 10
years that's right that's where our data
becomes so valuable and track you too
precise exactly where you are what time
you're going to be there why is why is
all that relevant to the point I was
making an answer to your question
because
what that really means is that that
we've got to reevaluate the societies
what value is what that really means
it's real value is not the data and the
money you can make out of that behavior
no that's actually monetizing where the
real value is the real value is in the
relationships I have because what that
data really is is a marker in a point of
time of a transaction I've made with
another person so actually the real
value there is the transaction which
involved contact with other human beings
that's the value we're seeking to
monetize that's what relationism it's an
understanding that actually we are the
value we are human beings and how we
interact with each other is what brings
value to life
so if you can recognize that actually
there's a better way of doing things and
that rather than monetizing and turning
every one of those micro interactions on
a relational level into through looking
at that through a lens of profit and
turning it into a transactional thing
instead if we recognize actually the
real value there is in the relation
itself
then the relational understanding of
Life fundamentally can be very different
we can start realizing that we bring
value in our human connections and in
our relations with each other which is
why for example I make a point
of leaving my mobile phone at home
whenever I visit the mosque because I
think that rather than sit there and ask
people for their phone number I have a
conversation with human beings in a
place in a sacred place look at people
in the eye and talk to them face to face
I deliberately through the entire
Ramadan left this thing at home
uh because that it's it's a gesture and
it's a small gesture which won't have
much of an impact but it's to make a
point there that the value is in the
relationship and I think an
anti-establishment in a Libertarian
sense in a good sense of that word
anti-establishment an anti-establishment
Faith tradition recognizes actually it's
the Human Relationships that are
important and I think that's one of the
most appealing things about it but I
don't think people should be worried I
think that um you know we've got bigger
problems let's take that demographic
explosion that you're mentioning for
example I mean you won't find much
traction in that demographic that's
growing among Muslims which is going to
become a very large demographic you
won't find much traction for the idea
that men with penises are women
for example so there's a lot to be
hopeful about a lot of this woke crap am
I allowed to swear yeah so the [__]
that has no traction in Muslim
communities nor did the coveted mandates
by the way some of the biggest opponents
of this whole mandate era doesn't in the
Muslim Community that's right why not
again back to this point when you all
when you all
tuned out of the bullsh
Data Tracking the the the the Matrix
illusion that we all live in when you're
just with people none of this propaganda
you know I just spent a whole month in a
in a mosque every single night because a
Ramadan uh praying uh not just the five
daily prayers and not just the special
Ramadan evening prayer which is the
Tarawa prayer but also the tahajid
prayer the night prayer every night just
leaving my phone at home speaking to
people I can promise you out there in
Muslim communities the numbers you
mentioned whether it's in Pakistan
whether it's in Indonesia there's
because they are so tuned out of this
propaganda and that's the reason why
again has years of EX history behind it
you know not trusting Western propaganda
and all that because of colonialism
there's a long history there but because
they're so tuned out in the real world
where people are talking and mixing with
each other the fight turned out
uh not dependent for their perspective
of around life on the very narrow
um uh sources of information that we
have ended up with in uh in our
discourse and covert demonstrated that
in the way in which our sources of
information were so minutely controlled
these are communities that have because
let's take Pakistan as an example with
vaccinations as Vox reports you can pull
it up if you want but the CIA in its
hunt for bin Laden engaged in a fake
hepatitis B vaccine program against
children using the cover of vaccines to
try and take people's DNA against their
will by deception uh looking for bin
Laden that got revealed which is I say
it's on a Vox Vox that got blown up the
CIA to apologize for it but where you've
got a history of abuse like that nobody
trusts the messaging in the first place
to say take this shot or you're going to
lose your job everyone has their
starting point is you're all a bunch of
liars so when you're tuned out in that
way what you've got left you've got no
money
it's a developing World you've got no
power what you've got is relationships
and your relationships are the only
thing that matter as anyone with a
middle eastern background know the idea
of
um in Pakistan it's called safaris but
the idea of it's who you know you have
to know people your family your tribal
members even to get on in life because
the system doesn't work the system has
never worked for a long time so it's the
relationships that matter now in that
content you've got no time for the
[__] and the propaganda so there's
no traction for this uh these woke
culture wars there's absolutely zero
attraction but good vaccine mandates but
but it has to be because somebody at the
top shuts it down yeah because if the
person at the top doesn't shut it down
then there can there can be traction
okay you know there's a part about uh so
if you want to pull up the stats I just
send it to you with the whole percentage
of
um uh go a little lower go a little
lower go low lower goal keep going keep
going keep going
um let's see if this is the link
percentage of Muslims who support gay is
the article that I found yeah if you
can't go to that one and it says by age
uh I don't know if you see okay I I
didn't send you this link I sent you a
different link I sent you the peer
research link maybe I sent you the wrong
link okay let me send you this one if
you can pull this up it says percentage
of
um
Muslims who strongly favor gay marriage
okay 18 to 29 yeah 49 yeah 30 to 49 38
was that in America this is pure
research yeah but who's being is it
Muslims in America so this is Muslims
who strongly favor or favor gay marriage
okay presidential Muslims who strongly
favor or favor gay marriage who are ages
this is a table to put margins Arizona
question it doesn't say if it's America
let's just assume it's America I imagine
it would be 50 those numbers don't 50 to
64. 50 to 64 age 11 65 plus is two
percent how different is this in Muslim
nations very different give us an idea
it would be the opposite you'd be you'd
be seeing the exact opposite right there
on the chart if you see okay just a
survey just survey which countries are
legally allow in Muslim majority
countries where this is a uh a legal
where the definition of marriage has
changed from being between a man and a
woman in Muslim majority countries I
don't think there's any any really uh
attraction for this idea but which which
Muslim countries is gay marriage legal I
don't I can't think of one what do you
think about that look for me this is a
human
a human issue I don't think we should
have to change the definition of what
marriage is
to have sympathy for people that have
same-sex attraction I think that there's
a there's a lot of crossing of lanes
here which I think has been largely
responsible for some of the mess We Now
find ourselves in where where where men
are saying they're women I think
tradition is important it needs to be
respected and maintained there's a
reason in Tradition marriages between a
man and a woman uh civil unions and
civil Partnerships are something else
I'm not uh into in any way persecuting
minority identities my interest is to
make sure that tradition as well is
preserved and not tinkered with because
what we've seen of lake with the woke
culture wars and said we'd come to the
trans thing and maybe we can go into it
here now is it the absurdity of this all
becomes apparent when you start there's
tradition is there for a reason and the
wisdom that underpins a lot of our
traditional perspectives in time you can
begin seeing especially as you become
older and become a parent and if you
start playing with that
um wisdom as I say the absurdity becomes
apparent now there is no uh there is no
reason
other than
a respect for tradition and and a
recognition of reality which is what
tradition is I believe and the wisdom
that is underpinning tradition is based
on
um there is no reason other than that to
object to a lot of this madness that the
reason I object to this man is I say
that this we as human beings have
existed here on this planet for so many
thousands of years and along you come
and think that you can that you've
suddenly found an answer
to these questions and the answer is
that I can identify however I want
sorry but I don't think that you have
the accumulated wisdom of generations of
human beings on this planet
um people that have had intersex
identities people that have have had
trans idencies people that have had
same-sex attraction have always existed
in these societies and if you go to
um Pakistan as an example here if you go
to Lahore
and if you go to the batra Masjid which
is one of the big most beautiful mosques
in law around that badshah Masjid was
the traditional red light district of
the Mughal emperors uh because a lot of
the concubines and others would live
around the court
and the in Pakistan there's a very old
tradition of
um
men that would come to weddings and
dance and they would be dressed up as
women
and in order the common parlance for
this is yeah and uh it's not you know
the the idea of the the trans identity
in a traditional Muslim Society is not
um it's not alien but what what never
happened was that you take that
phenomenon which was they weren't you
know of course there are challenges with
uh how they're treated and that needs to
improve in every case but what never
happened was you take that identity
which has existed there for a long time
and now you want to start tinkering with
tradition by changing uh the norms and
the customs and the legislation upon
which those that those norms and Customs
lead to by saying that I'm going to
announce change the definition of
marriage so they they were there and
they've always been there but there's a
reason that that tradition has led to
this idea that marriage is between man
and woman I think and I think that's how
it should stay it's also slippery slope
right because uh you said that's how I
think you should stay is what you're
saying marriage marriage marriage
between a man and a woman that's how it
should stay okay so uh uh today you'll
hear guys coming out and you know we
talk about this with Tate Andrew Tate
says look at Christians you know they're
compromising their values and principles
he says you know why I'm a Muslim
because they don't compromise the
Verizon principles and he's he's got a
big audience and his audience is who
16 to 35 years old okay which is the
audience that is typically afraid angry
disappointed heartbroken moldable
shapable recruitable his audience is the
audience that is a shapeable audience
right it's the audience the US
government wants to have because the
sooner you get to them through
educational system whatever maybe you
have them for the rest of your life and
you already know how they're going to be
voting for you got them for the most
part right okay
what what why do you think uh the the
Christian religion is caving in where
they're sitting there and saying well
you know what it's okay you know it's
just compliments okay and I know you
don't have the answer to it it's not
like it's like I'm looking for definite
but I want an answer of your opinion
I'll give you add on Sir um and by the
way do you think it is a mistake
clergy's men do you think it is a
mistake the Christian church is making
yes yes so add-on sir and before I give
the an answer that I'm saying I to make
it clear I'm married to an American who
was raised in Catholic School my mother
in law is a practicing Catholic who
visits church every Sunday and for all
the occasions such as Christmas and what
have you
um
and so I am familiar on a in a family
sense with um Catholicism and my remarks
are in no way meant in any way to
disparage any faith tradition
but an answer to your question I believe
is back it comes back to the nature of
uh institutions in this case clergy
when you have as I say every institution
becomes corrupted and it drifts to more
and more power we saw that in the church
so the pedophilia Scandal isn't confined
to Epstein it existed in the church as
well
now what was Epstein so Whitney Webb's
written a book One Nation Under
blackmails a two-volume book worth
having a look at um I interviewed her
for my the radical show um which uh
basically we had a whole season and then
um it was on Odyssey and odyssey's
parent company was library and the SEC
um the Securities and Exchange
Commission under Gary Gensler enforced
against Library while not enforcing
against uh FTX
and celebrity had to shut down and so uh
uh
Odyssey the platform still exists but
radical the show couldn't carry on but
we had Whitney Webb on that show and
that's an example One Nation Under
blackmails her book and it goes into how
the entire Epstein operation was for the
purposes of acquiring compromat on
senior political leaders so that once
you have that compromat or compromising
material you can have them do your
bidding at risk of you exposing what you
know about them if they don't
so take what we know about Epstein and
one of his um former handlers is it's
all there in the press in fact in the
British newspaper the sun you've got an
interview with one I'm saying I was
Epstein's Mossad Handler and the reason
we were doing this was to try and force
politicians with the compromat we had to
do our bidding but that's how political
blackmail works so to your question what
happened in the church
if you've got a whole bunch of [__] on a
whole bunch of priests doing a whole
bunch of crap with kids
you can have them do your bidding and
you can hijack the institution from
within in the UK with the church of
England um I think the man's
um well be head of the Church of England
in the UK has recently come out and said
the same thing it's like yeah it's fine
this trans stuff this gay stuff it's all
for so the question becomes if you can
corrupt the institution from the top and
the guidance itself is saying this is
all fine
or in the case of the Catholic church
you've got priests who are
disabled from doing much against it
because themselves are compromised the
institution itself becomes disabled it
is unable to respond
and again the advantage of an of a more
libertarian approach to a direct
relationship with the source or Allah
again we've defined what we mean by the
word Allah this is not a you know a
Muslim only thing
um if you have a direct relationship
with Allah or the source uh you can
always outflank the attempt to hijack
any given institution because your uh
your faith tradition doesn't rely on
that Institution for guidance in the
first place
that's so imagine let me ask you a
question so what uh I I agree the whole
Trends it's it's it's it's getting crazy
they're growing by the day it's getting
to me it's getting out of control why do
you think such a small minority group is
is getting like protected and probably
you can't like if anybody talks negative
against them you're canceled you're done
you're finished how are they getting
this much power yeah how is it well so
this is deliberate these culture wars
are being stoked on purpose to avoid us
having these conversations about one
nation on the blackmail about globalism
about technocracy about the the uh
attempts that are still undergoing right
now to securitize the entire planet and
and put us under this Dragnet uh this
technocratic uh Dragnet where we are all
digital slaves uh and that should be the
most important topic right now the World
Health Organization is currently as we
speak passing amendments to the
international Health regulations
amendments those amendments to the
stipulate that the head of the World
Health Organization tudrus who I Believe
by the way there is also some
questionable footage of in various
private scenarios now tudros who's the
head of the World Health Organization
through these amendments which will pass
without a vote because all of us our
countries are signatories to the World
Health Organization so the amendments to
the international Health regulations
don't need a vote once those amendments
pass the World Health Organization can
declare a global Health Emergency and
impose all of their measures from a from
uh on top centrally and they won't need
the government's
cooperation to do so so we've got
efforts afoot right now as we speak to
securitize our uh Health policy around
the world and synchronize it all in one
globalist technocratic tyranny
and meanwhile uh we're fighting over
what a woman is and I think that that's
being deliberately stoked so that we're
looking over here and not looking up
like the version tactic like look left
and right don't look up and I I
obviously you have to address it because
somebody going into a female changing
room and you or a prison whereas a
rapist or suddenly identifies as a woman
and gets put into a female Wing you have
to address it because it's a clear and
immediate problem but while you're
addressing it this is all going on up
here so I often say to people look up we
have to look up and understand what's
going on this is being deliberately
funded back to the money Point these
culture wars are being stoked and funded
on purpose the rise of this bug-like
character notice it happened after they
met Biden yep right it's all plant so
let me Rob can you pull up the Eric's
wall well moment you know on April 19th
the tweet I sent you you should have it
somewhere that was sent out on Twitter
it's a clip uh it was sent to you
earlier if you can find it uh if you
just go to your text you should find it
faster than this because so it before
you do that before you do that I'll go
through what we just saw recently with
the United Nations back the
decriminalization of sex with minors I
don't know if you saw that on it I did
and you know report titled the 8th March
principles for a human rights-based
approach to criminal law prescribing
conduct associated with sex reproduction
drug use HIV homelessness and poverty
which goes into talking about sexual
conduct involving a person's below the
domestically prescribed minimum wage of
consent to sex may be consensual in fact
if not in law how in the hell does the
Geneva based International Commission of
jurists who wrote this in March with an
assist from una uh AIDS and the office
of United Nations High commission for
human rights how can this be common
sense yeah well it's not and they're
normalizing it because most of the
people who are in positions where they
can bring this about are complicit and
that's what Epstein revealed to us
Guillain Maxwell is probably the only
case you can think of of somebody being
convicted for trafficking underage girls
to nobody
and that's what we're witnessing and
these are people all of them and it goes
to the very top in the UK you can get
this documentary on Netflix which I
don't believe in American audience can
see and it's on the UK Epstein his name
is Jimmy Savile and Jimmy Savile is dead
now but he worked for the BBC was an
incredibly iconic and influential
cultural figure in the UK for all of us
growing up he had more cultural impact
than Epstein Epstein had never been
heard of until the Scandal but Jimmy
Savile was like a you know a household
name and yet was a demonic pedophile who
would go into the point I say demonic on
purpose those hospitals you will all
remember Diana Princess Diana the late
great Princess Diana used to visit were
the the reason it's since been revealed
that Diana used to visit those hospitals
those ones in particular is because they
were the ones Jimmy Savile at night
would have unfettered access to to rape
disabled children in their beds and
Diana in this guy in complete in Diana
in complete you know she was desperate
to try and do something about this and
eventually obviously the whole marriage
fell apart but Jimmy Savile why I
mentioned Diana in this context is that
the UK Netflix character right here
that's him he looks something like that
right you know it's it only got revealed
after he was dead after he died
naturally of old age because
he was so powerful he was Untouchable
and how powerful he was is what this
Netflix documentary goes into and it's
that he there are letters from the
current King Charles to him they were
best mates and he had access to
Buckingham Palace he had access to
pictures of them together but there's
more than pictures of them there are
letters you'll find letters of King
because it's all been published by
Netflix I don't know if in the U us you
can get this documentary but in the UK
you can now I give this as one example
because everyone in a position of power
to be able to do something about this
pedophilia stuff is complicit that's
what Epstein was about that's what Jimmy
Savile was about we've got to have first
of all a recognition of just how deep
this rot is
and then we've got to realize
it's that deep that the solution can't
just be hand people or execute people or
throw them in jail for the rest of their
lives because actually
look at some of the porn online and look
at some of the content that people that
consume porn are watching and you
realize this is a malady it's a disease
in our hearts in society we've got to
have a fundamental we've got to really
look at this thing Anew I don't watch
porn full stop
I used to I don't full stop I've given
it up for a long time now because I
believe that all of us morally are
complicit when we engage in that
behavior obviously we're not criminally
responsible like these people but this
stuff it poisons the heart forget
poisoning the mind it poisons the heart
so that's why this stuff is happening
because they're all complicit and they
want to normalize it so that Justice
doesn't come but Justice is going to
come how
the cat's out the bag now you look at
Epstein it's there's only so far take
the covered narrative is involved
there's only so long you can suffocate
the truth
the cat's out the bag you can you can't
put that Genie back in the bottle
and once it's out there it becomes it
does it's why sunlight is the best
disinfectant because it does many things
at once one of them is that you think it
now if you're a priest in the Catholic
Church who was previously engaged in
this kind of behavior you're going to
think twice whether it's because you're
worried about being exposed in a in a
blackmail plot or me too the way in
which the cultural debate has moved
since just three years ago
on all this stuff
um has has has has
meant that uh there has to be a show of
attempting to stop some of this but that
that's why they're trying to normalize
it because they fear that trials are
coming they fear that people are which
they are are so angry that they want
Justice which is a natural demand and if
we deny people Justice For example where
is The Client List
for Glenn Maxwell
where is this Client List and I know you
know I think Trump
um and others have mentioned this but
the question that you can if you can end
up in a situation where
where
the entire system has been dependent on
pedophilia to survive which is what
Whitney Webb's book One Nation Under
blackmail uh documents and everything
good we know in society only exists
because the people at the top that
brought it to us were engaged in evil of
the most severe sense you can think of
there's only so long you can keep a lid
on that eventually even if it's just to
calm people down and appropriate the
cause eventually a show would need to be
made that this has been addressed and
right now a show hasn't been made
because you've got one person a woman at
that none of the male clients gilet
Maxwell has been convicted even Epstein
wasn't convicted he was disappeared
whether he killed himself or was killed
or who knows but the idea that there has
been no justice the only person
convicted for this great historical
Scandal has been one female who
facilitated it as opposed to any of the
men that engaged in it yeah even Prince
the only are not convicted but prince
Andrew was just relieved of his Royal
duties he paid some money and that was
it the only way that happens is if the
people at the top are also involved to
be like hey you better take care of me
because I'm taking care of you it's my
point that's the only way that can
happen and by the way this kind of leads
me to this have happened April 19th can
you play this clip real quick this kind
of goes back to what you were talking
about earlier uh that you were
recruiting officers watch this clip here
this is Eric
swalwell which has been in the news for
messing around with uh you know dating a
Chinese spy and all this stuff and all
these other things that's going back and
forth and then Watch What Happens here
our rhetoric and to denounce
anti-Semitism and anti-police rhetoric
in this country so that Jewish Americans
and police officers can be safer
Congressman I do thank you now you're
bad trash watch this the gentleman
yields and now I recognize the
gentlelady from Georgia Miss Green
that was quite entertaining from someone
that had a sexual relationship with a
Chinese spy and everyone knows it they
moved to take our words down watch this
they work on taking it down after three
and a four minutes they didn't take you
down they kept it I don't this is very
uncomfortable to watch for four minutes
oh I love it but they kept it yeah they
kept trying to take their words down by
the way I'm not gonna play it if you
watch it it's it's right it just goes on
like this it goes on like this and then
they finally said what would you like to
have removed and they said everything
she said says we can't do that you got
to be specific we'd like you to remove
the part uh comments about spices nope
we're going to keep that in there it's
stained okay so that's a record yeah
exactly so that happened yesterday Pat
this happened again yesterday yesterday
they cursed another another Republican
male I forgot his name said the same
thing he's like you had a relationship
with Fang Fang he said her name and they
go nope strike his words down again yeah
so
I'm going to take a very weird uh turn
here maybe a little bit weird here so
talk across on what happened recently
yeah yeah so talking to him he's uh he
said he feels weirdly great by the way
yeah and by the way it's very obvious
that he feels weirdly great yesterday he
made a comment uh uh uh put a video up
if you can I don't want to play the clip
I just want to see how many views it got
it was at 5 million last night in like a
couple hours yeah I saw that clip where
is it at Rob if you can look up how many
views that clip has I just pulled it up
15.6 million views in 14 hours okay you
think he's got a bit of a reach but
here's the part here's the part Rupert
Murdoch
Fox okay
they're massive you know I don't know
how many of the shows on TV or there's
90 out of 100 to have the top spots
it's just they have all the slots right
that they have the talent there okay
it's Fox bigger than Tucker yeah Fox is
bigger than Tucker NBA is bigger than
Michael you know MLB is bigger than Babe
Ruth and we can go on and on and on and
talk about that but there's only one
Michael there's only one Tucker there's
only one this is not an easy person to
find and replace right absolutely so
how much of this
first of all when you pay 787
and you go to CNN's YouTube channel out
of 12 videos uploaded eight of them or
so are about you know Fox had to pay 787
Fox had to pay 787 600 000 views 800 000
views 400 000 views that's all they're
celebrating and by the way they should
be celebrating why though
because and what do they all say
record-breaking never in the history of
media has anybody paid
787 million dollars and they call us
fake news you are the real fake news and
all this stuff right okay and they did
Russia nobody did anything about it you
know they did you know January 6
nobody's fighting that they did all this
there's nobody filing a lawsuit to get
them and all this other stuff they've
not done that so guess what
to the public who doesn't follow the
news what do they say Jerry you're right
they paid 800 million dollars so how
much of this is you know pure
speculation no one's even this is a
conversation I have with another person
yesterday how much of this could be that
the black mailing could be going on
behind closed doors with Murdoch whether
he's trying to sell the company to
somebody unless if you fire this guy or
something from the past that came up was
one of his sons how much of that you
think could take a uh because this was a
shocker Tucker wasn't expecting this
this isn't like his last show is well
today's my last show so I'm not saying
I'll see you soon
next week yeah so I mean look Hunter
Biden's laptop isn't it to your point is
an example of where Biden the president
uh would one assumes act conflicted to
protect his son if black man was
revealed about his son and there is
incredibly compromising criminal uh
behavior of Hunter Biden on that laptop
it's documented and if somebody an
intelligence agency had that information
and said to Biden hey we will release
this about your son unless you do X Y
and Z of course a father's gonna my son
I'm gonna have to look after my son so
to your point of course this is we now
know this is how the world has been run
and it's just incredible that it's all
come out at this moment
I think there's a reason it's come out
at this moment because we're in this
period of transition we're in really the
word historic is overused but genuinely
in a historic period where perhaps even
Fiat money comes to an end
um and the world is going to be
reorganized
um Murdoch won't live for long now just
because of his age a normal Soros I
think all of these old dinosaurs uh will
pass on and uh that's what the
struggle's about we're in this kind of
struggle right now but their kids will
take over well that's the struggle how
and who you know and and with Murdoch
again likewise you know which son who
how all of this and do they do the same
thing do they do different things and
we're seeing the instability we see now
everywhere is this it's succession on
crack because a generation is dying
Biden's octogenarian wants to run again
I don't know how long that guy's gonna
survive but a generation Madeline
Albright we've already mentioned has
passed on a generation that destroyed
the world the way they did and and now
we see that because the Mirage has been
lifted
um they're moving on and how those chips
fall and how the world's going to be
organized going forward is going to look
very differently the best we can get out
of this situation is decentralization so
what I mean by that is
if we if we recognize institutions
become corrupted and and over time seek
to centralize more and more power which
becomes more and more corrupting then
the way forward should be in my view
multilateralism decentralization uh what
Tucker's doing with his own this thing
that you know that studio I think that's
his main in Maine I've been there with
him in that studio and you know he's got
his own outfit there he's got a very
fully functional Studio it's a converted
bar and it's beautiful by the way if you
see it Rogan what he's doing what you're
doing decentral what I'm trying to do
but I'm very very heavily Shadow band
online so my my voice no longer has the
reach it used to but uh they consider me
too dangerous but that's fine
um but what we're all trying to do which
is uh decentralization of messaging so
that the power isn't focused and
concentrated at the top I think that's a
way forward so this is probably a
blessing in disguise that he's gone this
way uh because it means some people will
watch him some people will watch you and
you then have a genuine diversity of
thought the last tweet I put up before I
came uh on this show just a half an hour
before coming on this show is what I
said was
that
um you pull it up if you want
um I said that um the struggle for
ethnic diversity has largely
intellectually been won
um you'll see there it is the and it's
an appropriated struggle so I inserted
the word appropriately there but the
appropriated struggle for ethnic you see
I've lost my blue check because I refuse
to payment but the appropriated struggle
for ethnic diversity has already been
intellectually one the struggle for
Thought diversity and representation for
critical thinkers is what it's really
always been about and is nowhere near
one uh these two will now be
deliberately conflated by power with a
capital P in order to deceive what I
mean by that is that we this whole BLM
stuff is an example of it right it was
that the the movement was money
laundering from the beginning again I
called that out from day one it was um
for me it was obvious what BLM was about
and I've fought skinheads on the streets
with machetes I'm no I have no sympathy
for racism uh but BLM was a front it was
a sham
and the purpose is to weaponize and
appropriate these struggles which were
otherwise genuine anti-racism uh rights
for women uh but you appropriate them
because corporatism appropriates them as
it's done with a transgender and the
LGBT agenda as it's done with racism as
it in the case of terrorism as was done
to Islam when a machine appropriates
these these agendas to weaponize them uh
you end up in a scenario where what
they're really trying to do is catch up
with the debate that's already shifted
so most people are anti-racist the real
the real thing what it's really always
been about is intellectual diversity I'm
not really I don't care if this
conversation here
had four uh Middle Eastern Muslim men
who all thought the same that's not for
me the check box exerciser if we were
all sat here and all of us were Muslim I
mean that's all uh it's all tokenism
what I'm really interested in is
critical thinking and diversity of
opinion and that's what the
decentralized media space will finally
be able to bring about uh narratives
that have been critical of the covid
mandates for example that were so
suffocated uh if we decentralize then we
uh allow for the infrastructure to exist
that can that can actually always
protect the dissenting opinion because
it might be right it's why sub stack is
so important it's why most of my work is
on my sub stack page so imagine you said
earlier about the Reckoning which I I
hope something like that would come
about but what do you say to somebody
that for instance I think that there's
zero accountability when it comes to
those people in the top from bush with
the illegal War to all the people that
were that were killed from the covered
what we've seen with you know fauci back
forth back for the government line from
the Epstein thing do you genuinely think
that we're going to come to a point that
change will happen because like Tucker
is one of these truth-talking
accountability people do you think I
have to be like a spiritual shift like
the people are going to actually have to
come out and Revolt and actually go on
the streets because I don't feel like it
I feel like they have a grip a death
grip and we can't do anything the truth
is in your face and you can't do
anything so uh
I I believe there will be uh some uh
relief for us all we've had a very
difficult uh last three or four years I
I think it's about to get harder and uh
you think it's about to get harder yeah
yeah financial situation isn't very good
um and I think they want to bring in
Central Bank digital currencies and I
think what's your concern with that uh
Central Bank digital currencies are
essentially a tracking tool so when we
were discussing earlier about the fact
that um it's my data is valuable and
wherever I check my wherever I um tap my
contactless card leaves a mark that I
bought the bottle of water at that time
and you said tracking of course so
Central Bank digital currencies are
tracking that's what they are so in in a
sense I you take paper money away
um because it's we ended up printing so
much of it quantitative easing uh that
it's become pretty much worthless the
dollar standard globally is no longer uh
being respected uh China and Russia are
trading oil uh in Rubles and no longer
in dollars uh again it's unprecedented
Saudi Arabia considering the same thing
uh just four years ago this would be
considered impossible to do so paper and
the reason it's happening is because the
Federal Reserve has made a mess of of
money and the money system so what they
want to bring in instead is Central Bank
digital currencies and what you can do
is if all of our currency is digital and
it's run by the Central Bank you can
program it and so you could say right
imagine you know you've had a this was a
coffee I spilled it on the way in there
um
yeah they're white as well but um uh you
could say right imagine you've had this
is my second coffee today because I'm
jet lag from the travel uh you've had
two coffees today and so next time you
try and buy a coffee that's your quota
map and and you can't you won't visit
basically be able to buy it now with
coffee that sounds Petty but we know
that's what they want to do with red
meat we know that they've told us they
want us to eat more bugs as opposed to
red meat so if you've got a central bank
digital currency that is programmable
which we also know is an article in the
telegraph Rob which you may want to
bring up but um
it it might be behind a paywall though
but uh the the bank of England has told
us that these Central Bank digital
currencies will be programmable
um you might want to look up the word
Bank of England cbdc or digital
currencies programmable and and the
telegraph article with the word
telegraph in there and it should come up
as well at the bank of it there you go
in that article there programming you
see it Bank of England sales ministers
to intervene on digital currency
programming wow digital cash could be
programmed to ensure it is only spent on
Essentials or Goods which an employer or
government deems to be sensible you
can't like this is from 21. block you
from eating or doing something that they
don't want that they deem wrong yeah so
so in answer to your question I do think
so this is how it's going to get harder
right Tom Martin a director at the bank
of England said during a conference on
Monday that programming could become a
key feature of any Central Bank digital
currency in which the money would be
programmed to be released only when
something happens yeah so so you've had
you've had I had a steak for dinner last
night right you know we in the UK I get
I recommend South Asian food but if you
want a steak you have to come to America
yeah it's a it's a Brick Lane yeah who's
been
I'd probably give you some
recommendations that are off the beaten
path a bit more for proper good seafood
but that's a topic yeah but
um I haven't had too much steak this
week there much that's my that's it you
can't have enough so they can program it
you've met your quota and this whole
carbon [__] right that eating this
piece of steak is bad for the
environment so sorry but you can
literally can't purchase that anymore
because the cbdc is programmed it
recognized that yesterday Majid had one
so tonight maybe I want another steak
can't buy one you know so that's how I
think it's going to get worse but in
answer to your question back to the I do
think there's hope
um and and whether that's spiritual you
mentioned spiritual look you know
Breitbart said that um that politics is
Downstream from culture right I agree
with that statement politics is
Downstream from culture but I had
another statement I had a I amend it and
I say yes politics is Downstream from
culture but culture is Downstream from
spirituality
our culture is determined by our
spiritual uh
I don't say perspective presence our
spiritual Tranquility determines the
kind of culture we bring about and these
wars and on the trans stuff and that is
a direct manifestation of everything
being commodified and US viewing the
world through this transactional lens
that we spoke about earlier instead of
through the relational lens
um the trees
underground to coordinate with each
other through this beautiful mycelial
network of fungi and they they talk to
each other you know that they've
discovered that trees even recognize
their children through this underground
fungal Network and send nutrients to
their offspring underground like a
mother would uh you know provide food
for the child before themselves like a
parent would right trees do all of that
and they communicate uh underground we
are all part of that huge organism yeah
in a sense we're all connected like that
uh just because we don't see it that
doesn't mean it's not there it's
evidently clearly there uh but when you
divorce the human from that and instead
I view all of you as potential
Commodities to be exploited the end
result is some of these work culturals
we see where everything including
children have become commodified for
profit and porn is an example of an
industry that does that too so
I think that spiritually you mentioned
spirituality when I say politics is
Downstream culture and culture is
Downstream from spirituality we need a
fundamental spiritual reform of
ourselves and how we view life and our
our Tranquility that we uh that we are
missing I believe spiritually and I
don't prescribe religion I'm not into
saying Islam is the only truth I'm I'm
of the view that actually
um if we truly understood Allah the
source then you stop trying to convince
people you're right instead you try and
heal from within and you realize that
everything there's a word in Arabic
called fitra which means your natural
disposition
and it comes without effort you start
seeing of course I don't want to exploit
that child because that child is me it's
my child and it just becomes a given
it's not even something you have to
think about but that comes only with
this Sakina or spiritual Tranquility uh
within once you have that and of course
without that because if you're if we are
viewing all of life through this kind of
transactional lens where everything is
to be exploited
um in the end even our own bodies become
exploited for profit and that's what
transhumanism is about and the whole
idea of digitally modifying uh the human
body and and Elon musk's brain implant
uh what's it called neurolink so so the
sacred this sense of I was speaking to
Jordan Peterson about this on his show
the sense of of everything that has been
sacred is being destroyed and
commodified and it's what I meant by we
have to respect tradition there are
certain things are sacred for a reason
childhood is sacred for a reason and it
shouldn't even have to be argued it's
it's it's self-evident but of course
these days we have to explain why but
these uh sacred things to do with life
I think that we have to have a spiritual
Revival of of understanding why being
why the sacred is so important uh and
then uh through this period of hardship
I think we're coming towards there will
be I believe in the end there will be
some release
um because again they have to they can't
keep continuing that there is no justice
in our democracies anymore but right now
I bet all of us on this table if we were
asked very few of us believe justice has
been served whether against fauchi
whether against any of Epstein's clients
uh none of what we've lived through and
all of us have suffered and the economy
and the state it is and all of us
whether it's the invasions of these
foreign countries and these neocon cabal
that keep funding War they are acting
with impunity we have not seen Justice
what does that do to the buy-in to the
system and what does it do to people's
lack of trust in authority figures it's
corrosive eventually something we'll
have to give and I do think in the long
run we will see something different I
hope so well I'm from your inshallah I'm
from your camp that I believe eventually
something's going to happen by the I
want to head up this Tucker Carlson
three stories before we wrap up but
breaking news Jerry Springer just passed
away and you know Jerry and I didn't uh
sit down together six years ago five
years ago seven years we had a great
conversation together but he literally
just passed away moments ago I was just
about to tell you that yeah yeah God uh
may he rest in peace what's your biggest
memory of your sit down with Jerry
Springer
[Laughter]
Jerry Jerry the entire time was a fight
from the second oh we sat down we're
going back and forth back and forth back
and forth back and forth back and forth
it was constant what was this versus
what was the debate what were you on the
debate was over you know uh Trump
because I want to say the year it was
and obviously he's not a trump supporter
yeah and he I said how much taxes are
you willing to pay he says yeah I don't
care about taxes I said Jerry are you
talking as the Jerry today that's the
multi-millionaire or the Jerry that was
25 years old coming up that he is trying
to make his millions yeah yeah and says
no I would pay 90 taxes if that's the
case why did you move your show away
from New York to Connecticut to get tax
incentives in the city so anyways it was
a by the way it's a very fun debate back
in foreign
we were planning on doing a second one
obviously by the way he was a former
mayor I believe Cincinnati yeah
how you've um how you've had sympathy
for a dead person while disagreeing
that's how I think we should have oh I
had one we left laughing and and just
great conversation and it's okay let's
do another one but it was a great great
conversation we had together I want to
wrap up this thing with Tucker Carlson
because some new story came out first of
all oin uh uh uh rumor has it and it's
been revealed that he's been offered 25
million dollars for a new job by oan
okay Russian uh uh Network I think
Russia RT no art are you serious no no
literally Carlson receives a job offer
from Russia Today TV after Fox firing
that's an independent news yeah and then
the other two which are the interesting
ones Tucker Carlson you know where in
one of the texts about Dominion when it
was settled it was revealed the
embarrassing internal memo including a
text were tucked across and said Sydney
Powell is lying so Sydney wasn't for the
Dominion thing and that text has been
revealed which is not a good look for
Fox it is a good look for Tucker for
what position he took at that time but a
couple different things here Taco
privately called a senior Fox News exact
the seaward and wanted the world to know
about it as well this is a Wall Street
Journal story
he was not uh he was unhappy that his
use of seaward against the senior
executive was uh re redacted from Court
oh wow he's like put it in get it
the minion lawyers he was deeply
embarrassed uh those words had come to
light Carlson's popularity at the
network had wanted significantly and you
know anyway so that's that part and the
next story is about how Rupert Murdoch
freaked out this is Huff Poe said rubert
report suggests that Tucker Carlson was
fired over prayer talk yup freaked out
Woodward Murdoch Tucker Carlson was
allegedly fired from Fox News over
remarks he made during a speech Friday
night at the Heritage foundation's 50th
Anniversary gal in Maryland that were
too extreme even for Murdoch according
to vanity fairs Gabriel Sherman who
cited a source briefed on the
decision-making process look what he
said Pat he's because then think about
it we're talking about spirituality and
God and Allah uh Tucker uh called
abortion child sacrifice uh he said it's
a war between good and evil and he goes
people should take it's a day to talk
about I saw that clip and the child
sacrifice thing I want to give context
to what he said there because he was
very clear to be fair to Tucker he said
I understand if a woman's raped I
understand if a woman's health is at
risk I understand abortion in individual
cases he goes that's different to saying
abortion is a good thing to do exactly
full stop blanket yeah and he said I've
got every sympathy for these individual
cases I'm not arguing against those so
to be clear what he that this word child
sacrifice he said if you've got a policy
that says it's a good in society that's
what he said is a policy of child
support of course now how that
frustrates Rupert Murdoch to want to
turn on that yeah and you know say
that's the reason that's a little bit so
then that that to me says more about the
direction they want to takes facts okay
and by the way here's here's the crazy
part the moment a Chinese company uh uh
owned Forbes 95 of Forbes was owned by a
chinese-owned company everything about
the brand Forbes how to build out
decades on top of decades on top of
decades disappeared like this it almost
felt overnight but it took a couple
months today when you look at Forbes
it's not my opinion it's not the Forbes
of what it was five years ago ever since
that transaction took place a company
like this like look at what happened to
Twitter at the moment Elon Musk bought
it Twitter was playing a very important
important role for silencing a lot of
people the moment musk bought it now
there's a little bit more freedom the
moment Spotify kept broken that was a
little bit more freedom the momentum
Rumble is creating that's a little bit
more freedom this hurts conservatives
with Rupert Murdoch doing what he just
did to Tucker but going back to what
he's saying the decentralized voices and
the podcasts and shows will eventually
Prevail but this was not a battle this
is going to be a real war real real war
going on for a few more years I don't
think it's going to slow down and just I
don't know if I may provide some
spiritual backup for what you just said
um this passage in the Quran is is
actually revealed in the context of
Jesus ASA Ali Salam who's a very well
recognized beloved Prophet for Muslims
as well and the spirit of God the word
of God all of these are used to describe
Jesus in the Quran but this passage
they scheme in the context against Jesus
they scheme and Allah schemes and Allah
is the best of schemas wow
um and so you see all of these schemes
But ultimately I think that they will
lose I agree with you I think
decentralization will win out in the end
it's inevitable but it comes after
hardship
with the hardship comes the ease but the
hardship will come first the fact that
they lost this guy yeah yeah there's a
difference when you lose somebody
age-wise say you're 68 years old and you
have a show okay you sign up for 10
years that's what 78. Tucker is 54. okay
he can go for 15 more years if he wanted
to he can go he's 10 more years
and he is he is at the peak of his
career right now what he chooses to do
next is going to be obviously on him but
by the way the the lady they talked
about that he gave the c word uh uh uh
she was on media mediaite's website as
the number one power player in media
Suzanne Scott which I don't think he's
alone there a lot of other people have
felt that way as well allegedly based on
yeah but anyways yeah but you feel about
not to get you off pack but you guys
feel the it's all the people that are
speaking truth and wanting to hold
people accountable that are all getting
fired or they're taken down and it's
like that that's the Fate that I'm
having so this is coordinated in the UK
when talking this happened to Tucker in
the UK we've got one Member of
Parliament called Andrew bridgen how
long do I have are we out of time or can
I you can go two minutes okay so there's
Andrew bridge in the UK he's a member of
parliament he's just been kicked out of
the conservative party the ruling
governing party in the UK uh because
he's been the only champion of vaccine
injured in Parliament the day after this
happened to Tucker they kicked him out
of the uh of the conservative party tell
kilogram just got banned in Brazil by
Lula so you're seeing that this is the
clamp down the clamp down on these
decentralized voices is is on they're
attempting to shut us all down I mean it
happened to me during the covid period
and um again I had offers from other
stations but I knew that what I say it
can't really be on these platforms are
you still will get it or no um no I'm so
my my Radical Media is on
substance.substack.com and I do a rumble
show every Tuesday where my brother will
smon Raja we have he's my co-host
um we have a show on called Warrior
Creed or Rumble every Tuesday very cool
and uh uh Rob if we can put the links to
the rumble show at the bottom so that
can be found as well as well as his
books linked to both of them
um and the sub stack if you can it'd be
great endless upset yeah brother this
has been amazing talking to you thank
you I wish literally I wish we had two
more hours I can talk to you for four or
five I love that I love it to see what
direction learning all this stuff you
know different angles but uh I I hope
the audience enjoyed this podcast as
much as I did appreciate you for coming
out looking for would have doing it
again it's been a pleasure guys thank
you very much